so I understand that the two of you were
selected to be part of some type of
group of esteem screenwriters to go to a
castle and right yes and not to self
deprecated I don't know if it's a steam
but we were super lucky they they picked
it the associations called dream ago and
they run a workshop called penny
pelicula which is pen and film in French
and and they do cut of a writer's lab so
maybe and set up a little different but
a little bit the same as if you've heard
of the Sundance screenwriting lab so the
way they organized it was that they
brought in five or six professional
consultants who are have you know
writers in their own right or who have
been executives who work with with
screenwriters professionally and then
they 10 10 teams of participants we
there were two two or three sets of
different research teams yes we were one
of them and we were one and so you would
read everybody's script from you know
who was going and so you had a set of
you would meet with each of the
professional consultants and then you
would also meet with all the other
screenwriters individually and kind of
exchange notes so we ended up with 14
sometimes which i understand you wrote a
blog post ah little little bit of
research a good man research yet
two-headed monster about notes which i
find interesting how was that to receive
notes as a group versus maybe the usual
way of just individually well I yeah I
think that you know like for me since
this was my first time doing a workshop
of this nature I mean I went back to
school and got an advanced degree and so
we had workshop I had done workshops
with my work there but this was a lot of
first of all it was an international
group of people so there were people
from Cuba
from Switzerland and from France and we
were the only u.s. script that was
accepted into the program which I'm
actually quite proud of and the only
English language script that was chosen
so so we had in you know we had
translators and so there was you know
there were moments where we would you
know and barrington studied very
vigorously her Spanish I have some
Spanish background but neither of us are
fluent and so it was kind of trying to
make sure did we understand the
translation well did we understand the
context in you know so like my my
questions were always kind of you know
if there was a question about a note
then you know I wanted to know
specifically like where that came from
whether it be like a man that was
talking to us from Cuba who had a
different you know understanding of this
particular cultural world then than we
did and so you know it was it was
wonderful and exhausting and lots of
notes and so like that you know that's
what we you know we're really fishing
through and kind of sorting out like
there are certain through lines
thankfully that you know when people
were talking about deeper more complex
or those kinds of things that is easy to
understand and ride but then when
someone says oh this scene should
definitely not be there and someone else
says that scene is the best scene in the
whole film and you're like okay so so
it's just about for for me at least and
I was talking to barrington about this
this morning one of the things that I
had to do is like take into context all
the notes and all the comments and all
the everything and then go back inside
and go what am I really trying to say
here and what fits with what we're
trying to say and what helps strengthen
what we're trying to say
because they're there is so much like oh
that's a great idea or I never thought
about that or dang they want us to lose
that whole thing that was my favorite
part and so it really is about
remembering what the story is you want
to try to tell or at least that that's
kind of how I'm going at it and what
makes sense to help propel that to a
better place and so you know it was a
manic week of screenings and writing and
listening to criticism and eating which
you know we have no problem with but
it's it's intense it's very very intense
and so for me you know between the jet
lag and and also third things that
happened to one's body just trying to be
present trying to understand and trying
to stay awake and you know really fully
take things in because you know sleep
deprivation fits into all that stuff but
it was the most exciting thing because
in that you know in those moments and in
those opportunities you know getting to
sit at a bench that had a heartbeat
can't beat it for inspiration there was
there was a bench outside outside the
castle though it was kind of like an art
installation she's an art installation
and so like you you if you sat on it you
it would kind of start it was wrong
about it pulsates I thought you mean it
was a metaphor no no the actual physical
actual physical heart BTW or beating
bench and so I and that's kind of and it
was funny because that's where I SAT
when I was writing my notes about this
character and her mother who was
deceased being separated from my mother
who was in Los Angeles and I was in
Switzerland mothers on Mother's Day and
there's this pulsating around me and
inside of me and so it it was you know
and it
so funny because the you know and I've
told this story before you know some of
the consultants I just connected with
them you know like some of them I just
genuinely connected with them as people
and you know one of the the consultants
there was a really stressful evening one
evening and I was just like you know and
barrington was just like oh this is you
know she lets it out in one way and I'm
just like and to his credit he took me
out to the to the outside and he's like
just scream your head off just just let
he's like because it will make you sick
he's like you can't keep us a so I find
myself now like when things really
stress me out to just find ways to let
it go even if I just go to the beach and
just go there's a new movement that does
that really like primal screaming yes so
you know so I got more out of that than
just the writing I think that was really
important to me you know it feeds what
I'm doing as a writer but there was so
much more and even when that same
consultant and I were talking he's like
could this be done in Los Angeles and I
was like nope you could I don't think
you could do the same oh the long the
lab that that experience and get that
because we were in a small town as it
was surrounded by vineyards um it's it's
it's a very different kind of experience
like the town shut down on Sundays I
haven't met that since my you know young
days in the South like in you know and
now everything's open and you know like
where my mother's from everything's open
on Sunday but that place shut down
except for the cinema and one grocery
store was open to like two or three
something like that but it you know like
everything just kind of got quiet and
some of the rest of some of the pubs a
restaurant state
but it was just kind of like sorry it
was like this is Sunday yeah and I
haven't met that in a while so it's just
like wow so there were other experiences
that went along with that that to me
where we're inspiring and and I think it
it did bring Barrington and I closer
together I think because we had even
though we had traveled together before
this is the first time we'd been on a
plane together and travel offer 14 hours
together and we were working together we
were living in the same space before we
had we had gone to Austin for a film
festival but she came after i did we
were staying in separate venues and so
we would just kind of meet up like and
then we dined together you know like we
had to eat you know we we would often
eat together because sometimes we were
the only English speakers at the table
and other people will be talking in
their own language so so it was one of
those things where you know like I
learned a lot more about she and her
husband and how they got to get like
I've known her for three years I didn't
know how that you know like that how
that story came about and it had an
impact on you know when they gave notes
she was like yeah well you know when
when my husband and I were together this
was hot and I was like oh we can do that
yeah so I was like it was this really
great sharing of ideas and time and
personal space because like I said I
live alone so you know like I was with
Barrington for a whole week and you know
and you know she's like do I snore and
you know it you know in bathrooms that
you know women in bathroom space so so
you know so those things really did kind
of enhance the partnership in my mi
estimation even including the writing
yeah so you'd asked about just the the
note getting process Oh getting notice i
do it all on that tangent you cut that
off
but um okay but yeah so I guess two
things you know Janice talked about it a
little bit you know one is there's the
there's the actual moment of getting you
know getting the notes and how you
respond to notes and and she's somebody
who definitely like likes to kind of
follow up and ask questions and
investigate I'm a journalist and I know
and I kind of come from this this uh you
know writers within in writing parlance
they're like you're in the booth and you
don't really get to respond you don't
respond to notes when like for a certain
point like so there's there's a theory
of getting notes that when somebody's
giving you notes that that you kind of
try to stay very neutral because any
reactions that you give to them is then
going to provoke them to change the kind
of response that they're giving to you
because we have this humanity where we
don't want to hurt people's feelings and
we want you know people to like us and
and things like that so so you kind of
so I'm kind of like okay you know so my
just my natural I don't know if it's
natural but my over the years kind of
bond side together shape of things is
that you know I just I'm like okay maybe
I don't entirely understand that note in
the moment but I'm just gonna like
listen to all the notes and then that's
today me and then tomorrow me is going
to go figure it out so that's the ideal
right but then in practice of course
it's emotionally confronting all the
time and and for your like if you're
just by yourself and you're getting
notes then you you know you're all
you're going to be thinking oh well what
are they talking about can I fix this
and and where did this go wrong and data
so when you have two people you have two
people who were responsible for the
writing you have two people who are
thinking those things you have to people
who are who are kind of thinking oh yeah
that is a flaw and I thought it was a
flaw when we did it
this other person didn't think it was a
flaw and so you know it's uh it you know
it does bring you closer because you
have to work through all of that and and
say okay now we're going to go back to
the drawing board and and then later on
there's interpretation of those notes
well I don't know if they really meant
that note and like I don't was this the
it was this the important part or was
this the important part so it's it's
just another i mean it's its
collaboration right but it's it's it's
adding a layer of interpretation and
judgment to everything that you do but
it's also um it's kind of comforting in
a way because you have this person who's
with you when you're getting these
getting these notes and you know that
this person is supporting you and if
you're going someplace kind of emotional
if you feel safe with that person that's
a you know so it works both ways yeah
interesting with these handwritten notes
typed notes almost all verbal ogle okay
yeah so you're sitting there like yeah
sitting across the table from someone
and they're you know kind of maybe
they're referring to notes but they're
giving them to you person to person what
yes so how many writers were there all
together not not the actual note givers
but the actual writers being good south
13 12 to 13 there was one team who was I
was a husband-wife team and she was
there part time because they just had a
baby together so he was there full time
and then there was another writing team
Jack and um right yeah so ten scripts
and Jacques a general yes jerome road
yeah we're so so there were yes so i
guess it makes ten
1230 like 13 for yeah yeah so of the of
the writers that were there my champion
of the writers that were there at this
castle being critiquing what did you
observe about their temperament and how
they worked what were the similarities
that you saw like oh I do that too isn't
that funny that's kind of like writers
temper and then there's other things
that you maybe didn't identify with but
how are you so similar yeah well I
thought it was it's a very interesting
group because because a few of them have
an acting background and when you come
to writing from acting I think you're
coming from a little bit of a different
place so those people I thought I could
feel being you know they're a little
more extroverted and they're they're
kind of tend to be I think they're
approaching things a little more
emotionally from care you know from
character and then quite a few of them
were also filmmakers in their own right
like a lot of them were working on
documentaries war directors and so I was
I was really impressed just with the it
kind of a the comportment the confidence
that that people really seem to have
it's interesting how so confidence in
terms of how they presented their work
like they weren't afraid to show it ah I
think I'm kind of thinking of Julie just
like just calm and they've been around
the block a few times we're working in
kind of an independent film arena with
this film so I think here it's very hard
because you're really at the bottom of
the barrel people kind of look at
they're like oh the writings good but
who's going to buy it is who's going to
watch this who's going to distribute
this and you get to Europe where where a
lot of you know a lot of issue related
films a lot of documentaries they're
funded by the places that they come from
the state
funds you if you live in Columbia every
like while we were there we were kind of
putting together our our application
packet for Sundance labs but the other
people who were there we're putting
together their stuff for the government
funding from Columbia so you write you
know it's like I think here you spend I
don't I could be totally wrong I feel
like I'm somebody who spent a fair
amount of time studying a fair amount of
time aspiring and until somebody really
takes something and says I'm gonna pay
you for your time I love what you're
doing we're going to make this you're
still you're still kind of reaching for
that and so you're working in working
with people who are already there
they're like oh yeah I've been shooting
this documentary for seven years and I
know where the funding is for the post
and we're going to you know put it
together and then they're going to show
it somewhere it's kind of like maybe
it's that I'm like oh they feel more
grown up than me right okay I'm not that
they're working more or even working
harder or even you know that we aren't
kind of comparable in our knowledge
about things but there was you know
there was just kind of like a calmness
sometimes and then sometimes it's also
like being at summer camp look so by the
end of the week nerves are frayed
everybody's like on their 12th a set of
notes they're like yes yes you've told
me you know 12 other people have told me
that this flaw exists and now you're
telling me again and then people get a
little snappy sure you know the yes kind
of like the real world screen yeah yeah
they're like you know why are you
smoking on the porch why are you on the
porch if you don't want to be near the
smoke and you know like the shoes like
the real world starts encroaching
you